hello hello hello hello Chris hello Adam
and hello Odell Beckham hello Odell
Beckham mr. professional mr. do
everything right this offseason mr. you
deserve to be paid it's so great to have
you with us good to see you you see for
people that are only listening on audio
good to see you as well or hear you but
I was tired of reading YouTube comments
saying I like the old studio better this
podcast room it's kind of like empty
whatever so we're getting there I got us
a beautiful piece of art this is from
Tim McAuliffe you can see it on the
YouTube it is a really cool picture of
Odell back yes I just believe that this
is the summer of Odell I agree and we
should have his ear on one of the two
and yes our studio is going to get
decorated and it's going to look cool
for all use listening or watching we're
bleacher report remote Lenny old company
yeah it takes a little while for things
to get done here we are gonna have Mike
Florio profile pile talking like the
next two minutes yeah we're gonna teach
him a few parts of our constitution and
let him get into it some fantastic whoa
big off seasons we have a new segment
called incidental what I call accidental
insults so people that like got insulted
and I don't know if they meant to be
insulted right we're getting phil simms
back on we're gonna have a lot of talk
about practice you're a pretty good host
for bleacher report so Nick why don't
you give Florio a call I want to save
the big interview with Florio for
another time when he's in New York yeah
we gotta get that chair right but that's
where we should start it just right away
what do I not know about Florio that
we're gonna learn there's a there's a
lot to be learned this is I'm actually
equally as excited to talk to Mike
because as you know Mike does the show
from West Virginia so we're not together
and we don't always have time to just be
in the office like you and I and hey
what's up with life and what's going on
oh you there
yeah boy that connections horrible man
still like you're inside of a bug zapper
I can't I can't hear you guys at all it
sounds like a jet engine
ok let's go I'll call you right back
alright and that is the magic of radio
you little and that for you what are you
doing my house the hell's the West
Virginia mansion holdin up how you live
him it's well we've been invaded by a
dog so everything he's so I was just
explaining your living condition he goes
who you excited to talk to Mike and I
was kind of explaining them that you
know you and I our conversations are so
work all the time that we don't even get
to talk about life stuff all the time so
he started asking you about your house
in West Virginia yeah and all those
things I gave him a little rundown
everything are in West Virginia like I
had heard it but I still didn't believe
that you were there yeah and we kind of
tripped over the place that we live in
now four years ago the guy who owned it
owned a pool company and he owned a
winery so this place has like a really
nice outdoor pool set up and it's got a
nice wine cellar you've got a lot of
space it's worked out well because the
dog has a lot of a lot of stuff a lot of
area where it can you know it's run
around and you know piss everywhere it
has all the time I hope it shits in your
favorite place in the house I hope it
shits right on your favorite couch just
for you sending these scouting reports
like over the weekend of the dog like
the dog likes to lay underneath the
pinball's
dog it's like your first dog it's a new
dog five it did not go well but now
we've had this one for a week it's just
it's like having a baby I mean you know
constant gotta go outside kiss you gotta
you know be looking if it starts
sniffing around that it's getting ready
to squat and spray you know you just did
know it needs attention and he's a
running play and I like how he's
figuring out what it's like to own a dog
you know the dog just lives there and
you give it food and let it run outside
once in a while they didn't realize we
had to you know that it was actual
effort I I don't know that I would I I
don't because we love the dog but it has
changed everyday yes it does damn dog no
it's still early you can still return it
you can still figure to attach to it and
that's you think - I've fallen number
four in the household oh yeah definitely
not so we do at some point we want to
get you in studio right so during the
season or whenever you know whoever up
here which Mondays he usually is cuz he
does Sunday night football from the
studio and Stanford and then we do the
show together on Monday morning so
hopefully during the season early on we
can get you in studio in person have
some fun okay so you can meet the other
guy you know the substance the illegal I
know you met him but be around them more
you know this other guy just gotta soak
me in man really really really toast me
I'm gonna introduce you to a lot of the
segments that we do here on the podcast
but I just really had one question for
you and I'm sure you get this all the
time I just don't know how pro football
talks started like for me it's just kind
of been there and it's been one of the
front pages for NFL news I know that
you're a former lawyer and all that I
just how did it even get going wait are
we doing the interview now oh yeah the
whole dog shits gonna be on the pike I
was up a little bit more I mean usually
what happens maybe you'll eventually
learn this yeah when you're interviewing
somebody call them up like you shoot the
[ __ ] with them a little bit and okay
here we go three two one and you begin
to tape it look it's so much more
natural and fun now my to work wives
together is so fun he's all flustered
now yeah how did seriously know I've
never talked to you about this III truly
am interested in just about the idea and
how it all came to be what it is now
well here's what happened I mean this is
one of the great things about the
internet you could be anywhere in the
world
and you can have a voice and it was back
in the year 2000 I became aware of a
website called nfl.com
and I'm gonna give you the most
condensed Digest version is more
probably not but I'm going to give you
the simplest version of this that I can
I tripped over a site called nfl.com I
started going to that site they covered
the NFL in a fairly comprehensive way
and they didn't kind of edgy way and a
few months after I started visiting it
all the time because I never ventured
beyond the stuff that you get when you
put the AOL CD into your computer and
you know they have different areas like
Sporting News had football coverage but
I ventured beyond that and I became
hooked on nfl.com and in June of 2000
they were looking for writers and I
thought what the hell I threw something
together and I set it in I knew it
didn't pay anything but I thought it was
kind of neat that I could do this okay
and what were you doing at the time just
like for your normal job and everything
what was going on in your life as you
were starting to do that I just launched
my own law practice I've been practicing
law at that point nine years I've been
with a thermic Pittsburgh my wife and I
moved to West Virginia I was at a firm
I'd become a partner I decided I don't
want to do this for the next thirty
years so I started my own shop so I was
in the process building my practice and
I had time to screw around with other
things because I didn't have like this
whole plate of work that was keeping me
occupied all the time so hey this is a
perfect time to dick around with
something else so I sent in a sample or
two and a couple weeks later they ended
up hiring me although I don't know that
it's technically hiring because again it
didn't pay anything but I did it I liked
it I kept to a little bit more you know
eventually and your wife's always your
best protector because eventually my
wife was like wait a minute you keep
writing for this operation and I'm sure
they're making money off of what you're
doing but they're not paying that's okay
I mean it's a hobby I mean like if I
went golfing I expense big bucks and I'd
be gone for five hours I pissed off when
I got home and it kept growing and
growing it instead of age tensed it you
know I may be onto something here
because I think I'm pretty good at this
and and I just feel like it can end up
somewhere
some point where I do get pay for so
bottom line is the the stock market ship
the bed in early 2001 the tech bubble
burst for the first or second time I
don't know and this operation went out
of business it there any money left they
didn't come close to the revenue to pay
their expenses even though they were
paying me they didn't have enough money
to pay their expenses and so ESPN came
into bought the carcass and one thing
led to another and ended up joining
espn.com their insider service where you
pay whatever it is fifty dollars a year
and so I was writing for that while I
was practicing law it was like a weird
sitcom premise but I think the people
yes piant had no idea that I had another
full-time job it was taking a lot more
my time than what I was doing every
morning so basically of his 5 a.m.
I've worked for four hours for espn.com
I took practice law until I got
everything done for the day
and after six months they offered me a
one-year contract and that was when I
had kind of like that you know that
moment that epiphany that what am i
doing how I can't keep doing this and
where's it really leading and even
though they were paying me it's like
maybe there's something more out there
maybe I can do this in a way where I'll
have to pass it through five layers of
editors maybe it can be more
instantaneous maybe it can be more fun
on people tell me what to do so that's
when the idea was has to launch Pro
Football Talk comm November 1 2001 we
flipped the switch it looked like [ __ ] I
mean it was you know the basic website
from 17 years ago and why are you very
stripped-down and crappy but but you
know we just kept growing it slowly but
surely and here we are I've got 17 years
later
wait when when did NBC get involved and
go okay this mic Floria he's not so bad
he might have a few brains in there
well when Rick cornellà took over NBC
Sports digital operation one of his
first orders of business call me up and
try to do something more formal we had
done some things in the past through
roto world which NBC bought in 2006 so
early 2009 cordell our calls and saying
I don't want to do this because I don't
want to give up my independence I don't
want to have people telling me what to
do I don't want it to change I never
wanted to feel like an obligation that
was one thing I was concerned about we
went through this concept
almost like the athletic does now just
charging for content right because if 1%
of your of your readership decides to
buy it you're gonna make a hell of a lot
more money and I never wanted to get to
a point where it's not like a job where
it felt like an obligation where it felt
like a chore and that's one of the
concerns I had but when they called and
they were interested I said to them and
I wanted to scare him away so I did this
whole grandstanding thing like well I
got that final say over all content on
anybody tell me what to do that's it
that you know that's that's a deal
breaker and we're wasting our time if we
have this conversation assuming that he
was gonna say well we can't do that
we're NBC we can't just give you keys to
this thing and put up whatever you want
to put up but he said no we'll find with
that I'm like ah [ __ ] I got to come up
with another way to scare him off now
what happened that I still I still
resisted we had a couple of outages
because our traffic was getting to the
point where our technological capacity
couldn't keep up with it
we had an outage around free agency that
was horrible and means he came in and
saved us from that and we just basically
redirected our website to NBC sports.com
and they got to see the traffic that we
can bring in and I got to see how easily
they could service the people who were
banging on the door to get the
information and then around the draft
that happened again and after the draft
it was like you know what screw we just
have to do this deal even though I still
had misgivings I I realized the time had
come to do something and nine years
later yeah the best move I ever made you
know that's that's like I didn't want to
do it I fought it I did it I wanted to
come up with any excuse I could to not
do it and ultimately we did and it's
like [ __ ] you know what a great decision
even though it wasn't really a decision
that I made it was a decision that felt
like we had to we had to implement
obstacles the way men I think the thing
that's the biggest obstacle ends up
being the way all the time it's it's
it's amazing no matter what you try to
plan no matter how you want something to
be circumstance takes over your life and
it guides you in a way that you can't
control and you just kind of have to
ride it and see where it goes and I
think the harder you try to engineer it
the way you want it to be the harder it
is to force it in that direction the the
thing I'm so amazed about it all Mike
first of all I mean it is anime
website it gives you everything you need
as far as the NFL and you haven't taken
it he's left I don't know he hasn't
taken a day off from work since like
2003 but you used to say that I haven't
taken a day off you said something like
that to me once let me interrupt you
yeah please do I get to be the guest and
I can be an [ __ ] the whole time yes
like anywhere when you were on my
podcast yes I did
January 1 of 2004 the only way this
thing is ever gonna get to where it can
be is if I commit to it and the only way
to commit to it is to work on it every
single day I couldn't take a Saturday
off I couldn't take a Sunday off
I couldn't just screw around and and do
a little bit of work one day I decided
to go all-in
yeah and it's really not work so it's
like [ __ ] there's no reason that I can't
find time every single day to work on it
and once I made that commitment that was
when it really started to take off even
more than it had the first couple of
years okay that's all yeah that's what I
want to hear just because I am amazed by
that that you're right I just know if I
had to be you and be responsible for
that all the time I would go crazy going
like all it's Sunday morning I gotta
write something real quick or I got to
read about this news that it's a it's a
non-stop 24 hour
you know it's 24/7 job I think that's
Rafael baby NFL's no sleep so I've
always been impressed with that with
Mike even the ability of Mike like I am
pretty sure and I'd like you to tell me
the truth here man cuz I've never asked
you this when I'm talking on the show at
7:30 in the morning are you writing
articles as you're doing it right then
to it I'm still like not listening to me
or I just would like to know that I'm
definitely not listening to it I'll
admit that when you were telling the
story about throwing the football into
the cannon itself like you threw the
football at the pirate ship at the
Buccaneers stadium and you claimed that
it got lodged into the cannon I wasn't
paying attention and if I had I would
have called [ __ ] till the cows came
home there is no way you're gonna throw
a football into a cannon so I isn't big
enough it's gonna bounce off of the
outer rim that's [ __ ] no it's no no
so soon as give the official story right
of your throwing into the pirates I
scored
down I throw a playoff game against
Washington you roll out you dive over
the pylon touchdown touchdown I always
like if I score a rushing touchdown in
this endzone
I'm throwing the ball to the ship like
definitely that's what I'm gonna do my
first running touchdown ever on that end
zone
so I scored and I was like here it is
I'm gonna launch this [ __ ] up there and
I threw it at the ship now it didn't go
I wasn't trying to say it went exactly
in the cannon right
so can you just listen for a second
you're just like left go you big baby
shut up this so do you know the square
box that's cut out I guess for the
cannon yes I don't know I didn't see it
but I can tell you that on TV Paul
McGuire and Joe Theismann say it on the
telecast the ball not victor ball went
into the cannon hole and we have
actually gotten multiple comments on
Reddit Instagram of I'll never forget I
was there and I saw that it was the most
incredible thing I've ever seen so we
have gotten like people listeners that
claim to have seen what happened is
right so I again I don't know it either
and I would call [ __ ] him no I
didn't because then everybody as I
launched it up there I wanted to see it
but then people started jumping on me
and stuff and I couldn't see where it
hit actually and then I got fined $2,500
Laurie do you believe them now because
the consensus that was reached today we
were talking about on the show the only
way that that thing got remotely close
to the cannon is if you were aiming for
something else but screaming for the
mass that's I didn't say I didn't say I
was aiming for it I was just hoping to
hit the ship in some capacity all right
so let me Florio kind of welcome you
into the sims left go world and things
that we hold true
we're gonna go to those sims a left go
Constitution article 1 section 1 which
is Aaron Rodgers is the best quarterback
we've ever seen go ahead sing it first
night yeah sing a mic no no I'm not like
a dog the other guy's version is a
little
flower yes much more like fries he
sounds like the priest like when there
consecrating the communion exactly yes
it's the Church of Aaron Rodgers so Mike
Daniels had an amazing quote where he
said I think that Aaron should get a lot
of money and then he followed it up by
saying like a lot whatever a lot is
Aaron should get what Aaron requests I'm
not trying to get in the middle but I
think everybody in their grandmother who
doesn't watch football knows that Aaron
Rodgers is more than deserving to be the
highest-paid player in the NFL
dot-dot-dot history love McDaniels love
it my question for you Florio is will
rogers get anything in his contract that
will be game changing the way cousins
getting a fully guaranteed contract open
people's eyes I don't know because the
challenge with Rodgers is this he's got
two years left on the DLT signed back in
2013 and he only has himself to blame
for that committing for seven years and
then the Packers could tag him two years
after that before they get themselves
into a spot where they'd have to let him
hit the open market and that's how
cousins got that term he's on the open
market and all it took was two teams it
came down to the Vikings and the Jets
and he was able to leverage that free
agency into a three year fully
guaranteed deal and I don't think the
Packers are gonna say to Aaron Rodgers
okay we're gonna tear up what'd you do
to make over the next two years and
we're going to take that franchise tag
for year three and we're going to turn
it into a three ninety six million
dollar deal fully guaranteed I don't see
that now maybe he could get a term that
guarantees him a set percentage of the
salary cap in future years that's
something that guys like Darrelle Revis
and Kirk Cousins tried to get in past
seasons and couldn't or maybe what he'll
do is get a clause to kick his pay up a
hundred thousand per year above whatever
the highest average is if an winnings
leapfrogged
in the future I think something like
that is possible I know there was a
report that he wants to have like the
ability to rip up the deal and
potentially become a free agent I guess
if someone if someone ends up making
more than him I doubt the Packers would
ever agree to that but ultimately the
key is this what will what will prompt
the Packers to trade in what they
currently have and the bird in the hand
for the Packers is two more years of
certainty to your
the franchise tag I think I worked it
out once with what he's making over the
next two years and what the tag would be
it averages to just under 25 million a
year over four years what do they what
are they comfortable swapping that out
for when they have no obligation to do
it and they could take four more years
of Aaron Rodgers and let him leave at
age 39 if they really want to do that so
man it's gonna be hard for him he's
never gonna have the kind of leverage
that you have to have to get a deal like
that which is getting close to the open
market
or putting the team in a position where
you know the guy can justifiably
withhold services and then you're [ __ ]
out of luck and you don't have your
quarterback it's not gonna upset Aaron
though well that's why I mean Mike so
this is what I want to ask him like this
because Mike's amazing with contracts
rules yeah we want the players to get
all the money and mike goes from the
from the team's purse but it makes like
us to the mike is a player's guy all the
way we had this talk on the show
yesterday actually where he was like I
don't understand these are billionaires
and the fans support the billionaires so
he's on our side as far as that it's
great I know as far as but Mike do you
think like do you think Aaron Rodgers or
do you think it's even realistic for a
guy like Aaron Rodgers to have a
contract let's say to guaranteed he has
to be in the top five paid hot top
highest paid you know quarterbacks do
you think that type of language can
realistically be done like we see
College head coaches get those type of
deals do you think they can find a way
to work that in with the the way the CBA
is all set up oh they can do it there's
a lot of things they can do the problem
is the management council which is
essentially the group that runs the
league and and implements collusive
behavior throughout 32 teams the
management council would probably argue
against it you know there's a lot of
things I think the Management Council
keeps teams from doing because the
management council doesn't want one team
to start doing it because if one team
does it then another team does it then
another team does it and the players end
up having greater leverage but I think
there could be a lot of creativity
applied here and maybe that's what
they're trying to do there wasn't much
creativity that was applied back when
Aaron Rodgers got the deal in 2013 and
made him the highest-paid quarterback at
22 million per year but the problem
again he's signed for seven years and
now he's get the back end of the deal
and that's what players need to guard
yeah yeah year four five and six that's
where Julio Jones is right now
47 million over three years hey that's
great now he's on the back end and those
salaries don't look as good and none of
its guaranteed and he's looking at guys
like Kirk Cousins saying damn that guy
did a three-year deal that's what I
should have done and I think shorter
term deals are the way to go yeah and I
know that you take some injury risk but
if you can get a short-term deal for me
guarantee it screw it do that because by
the time you get to year four five and
six it wasn't gonna be guaranteed anyway
right that's right article one section
three beans not beef my favorite story
of the week Bill Belichick's Hotel order
has become big-time news he stayed at
the Loews Regency New York and he spent
sixty one dollars for his room service
blueberry pancakes
and coffee give it to a maid page six
what's my game I give it to his stats
jr. over here listen this was a plant no
I promise you I promise you Mike no Glen
I'm have it I promise you he said this
is what he wanted to talk about and I
didn't say my question is are you
surprised that Belichick ordered
blueberry pancakes I saw him as more of
a straight-up
like buttermilk first of all give it to
him all of it the whole thing because
what are you talking about because some
people have tried to make a big deal
about him like he paid for golden cup
pancakes it never stayed in a hotel
everything is so expensive I would get
my girlfriend if she stays me in a hotel
I'm paying a hundred and twenty dollars
for a fruit cocktail it's the worst
experience I don't know how this became
a story but I dislike late I just love
the fact that Belichick we know is a
blueberry pancake guy I just like that
information about maybe but maybe the
pant maybe maybe the pancakes were for
his girlfriend
that is right breakfast do we know hey
but that's what's amazing to me the New
York Post a newspaper that is in New
York doesn't realize that if you are
going to be in a New York City hotel and
if you are going to ask the people who
run the kitchen in that hotel to make
you your food and bring it to your room
it is going to be considerably more
expensive and if you drag your ass out
the elevator walk out on the street and
find a diner where you can go breakfast
then even though there's plenty of
tourist traps in New York there's plenty
of places where you get a good breakfast
reasonably cursed that place we went to
a couple of days last month but now
right there right yeah I mean it was
great yes the National the international
one or two I guess so you're you're
reading in the you're reading into the
details I am imagining Bella check
answering the door [ __ ] lawyer it's a
t-shirt and shorts be like things for
the blueberry pancakes that really
appreciate it and then his wife being
like you didn't get bacon he's like it
was $61 pancakes it just coffee I bet
when he gets room service I bet that he
hides in the bathroom while his
girlfriend settles up I've done some fan
asking him questions or or taking the
receipt giving it to the New York Post
yes that's what I can't believe
shouldn't whoever I mean if I was in
that hotel right and Bill Belichick's
room service bill ended up in the hands
of your post people would be out of
their jobs every time I see that like
anytime somebody posts a receipt from
TGI Fridays about how much some what did
kit for did how are you doing right
doing that first thing I thought of no
it's not I mean I got a bum Bill
Belichick I go [ __ ] clothes
I'm never going there again yeah I'm not
staying there I agree
all right last one this is another
staple of the podcast left go PR meaning
there's always an ulterior motive to why
people do things and Andrew Luck
throwing a football is the creme de la
creme
they threw a football and my first
thought was they're only putting out
this footage to remove the narrative of
Andrew Luck hasn't thrown a football for
X amount of days not announcing the fact
that it was like a place cool baby
football to Reggie Wayne do you or were
you like me flora did you see that story
and go oh this is just to ruin that
narrative I look yeah it's a high-school
football and and he the thing that got
me because I had there's Andrew Luck for
no footballs he he's fine he'll be fine
and he said yesterday he's absolutely
playing week one but when you look at
the details and we picked this apart
this morning on on the show on TFT live
when he said he had a mental block about
throwing an NFL football I mean yeah
who's the point I made
here at golfer and you're having trouble
with your 7-iron that you know use the
six you use the five when you're a NFL
quarterback if you can't throw the NFL
football if you've got a mental block
over that you're screwed mm III you know
Andy's out there at practice with that
goofy water football with the white
stripes on it tiny ball and it's like
wait a minute why can't this guy throw a
regular football yet and why are people
not freaking out about that six weeks
before the start of a training camp that
they are convinced he'll be able to
participate in fully and completely as
he prepares himself to absolutely play
in week one
and it's some of the same BS we were
hearing last year and that's why with
all of this my position is the Colts
have lost the benefit of the doubt I
don't believe anything they have to say
I assume it's all [ __ ]
right variety of reasons and I don't
know whether they lied to us
deliberately or inadvertently last year
but they lied to us every step of the
way and I can understand hey look you
want people to to be optimistic you want
people to buy tickets you want people to
show up for games but at a certain point
you have to say you know what we learned
our lesson last year we're not listening
to you this year and that's my attitude
toward the constant Andrew Luck they got
to show me a healthy player and when
they do that's when I'll listen to them
again but all this other stuff and their
Luck's in on it too you know he's stupid
enthusiasm and optimism and when you
listen to how he said what he said it
really doesn't sound as convincing as
the horizont paper otherwise would
suggest totally no knock on wood I
believe it in my bones but you just say
you actually hear him talk about it like
when you hear him say it it's not as
definitive one thing we learn on the
show we'll play sound of guys like when
Derek Carr was talking about working
with John Gurdon when you see what he
said it's like okay that's very
reasonable yeah he's getting used to
junk food and he's you know he's putting
in the work when you actually see him
say it and he's like doing the tells
like rubbing his forehead Ben and
pausing and it seems hesitant nervous
it's obvious that Gruden's wearing him
out the same way he wore out that's
right he's stressing as he's answering
questions and he's going how do I answer
this so this guy doesn't you know mother
F me when I'm in the meeting room later
today so we want luck to be better
where's your confidence level no I'm I'm
I'm with Mike and I think you two where
I'm truly concerned I've been there with
the mental block thing right okay with
my spleen injury man the ball didn't
feel right in my hand either I would
have been like please let me use a
high-school football I could throw that
better so to me if the mental block is
there it's because the ball doesn't feel
right in his hand right and it doesn't
feel right in his hand because his
shoulder and arm and all the muscles
aren't working right so here's a smaller
object oh this feels better I feel more
comfortable and again what did we see
yesterday we saw six yard throws to the
back we saw doing high steps and a
little toss to the coach so I'm with
Mike they've lost the right to like say
oh he's gonna be back I gotta see it to
believe it
I'd appreciate like guys like Chris
Ballard I think we will get a more
truven true narrative there yes because
he's I think a very honest guy and like
he came on the show right Mike a few
weeks ago and he was totally cool with
like I understand these questions I'm
not gonna like get my bricks and I would
be even doubly down right I'm just
scared
it's scary cuz I want this kid to be so
good because he is so good and he's such
a nerd and he's got a book club and you
know that he spends like 99% of his time
trying to get back on the field right
but all of the comments of everyone
around him is making it harder on him
like I feel like the Colts are trying to
help him and it's really just shut us
and let him just let Andrew do his stuff
but I don't know so we have we ever seen
this whenever ever seen a quarterback in
his prime miss an entire year and still
have uncertainty about his ability to
play right more than 18 months after the
fact it's not Colin athleanx in the
modern age Colin yeah of course I think
Peyton Manning's the only one baby neck
with a neck then he sits out the year he
comes back to Denver he's obviously had
that issue it's prime now you're right
yeah you're right I know I do you're
exactly right I'm just saying it's the
closest thing I can think of to this
let's end with you telling Florio that
he was right I think that's a good place
to end a floor that was right he was
right or this was fun I'm excited to do
this in person I know if we can only get
him to move
to West Virginia and come up and do the
show person somebody NBC is gonna hear
it say yeah why you never make that son
of a [ __ ] move Connecticut yeah they're
gonna call me up and they're gonna say
yeah you know what we were listening to
your show today and Sims makes a good
point in the ass for us having you down
in West Virginia so we want you to come
to Connecticut you can end up getting me
fired you bastard not gonna get you fire
but I might get your ass to move up here
eventually if I keep silent
I'll have to tell see you tomorrow
morning
All Right see men so let go can I say
something real quick yeah I like that
shirt Thanks that new it's what do you
special we already talked about it no
yeah I like it it's not new I haven't
seen it before I've seen it in the
makeup room no but if you haven't seen
you wear I mean I know your wardrobes
inside and out it's a good-looking shirt
I like it yeah looks like you should be
walking around the streets of Hawaii or
something hey cool cool a li what do you
think Oh Dell oh one other amendment
that I'd like to get other way so we've
done beans not beef Aaron Rodgers how
was the beans not beef part there though
that was any time we talked about food
it's beans a beef okay
like we know endings in yes Bill
Belichick should have gone with egg
whites yes you know maybe a little
spinach
he went blueberry pancakes in a black
coffee yes you think Bill Belichick puts
cream in his coffee mmm yes you do I do
oh I thought he'd be like just give me
brown water I think he likes the sweeter
things a little bit I think he thought
sugar package sweet'n low article 3
section section 3 grass not turf Reggie
Bush gets 12 and a half million dollars
from the Rams
damn if you've ever seen that footage
where Reggie Bush is running in the in
the Edward Jones Dome knew I should have
my spleen got nearly 13 million dollars
from the Rams
because he fell in that Stadium and it
like ended his season I don't know the
my grass not turf yet another reason
they should be playing on grass another
reason why why the NFL would even let
that [ __ ] happen on a stadium where
professional athletes play oh we're
gonna six feet from the field we're
gonna have a
Kri patch that cleats can't stick into
you no I mean no guys don't ever get
pushed out of bounds aggressively in the
football never that's just that's to me
another area of the NFL where I look at
why don't we have people there on a
weekly basis you know as that games
replay official checking the ball
pressure whatever it may be all these
things the NFL cuts little corners is is
so expensive Chris I know it's cost
money it's so disappointing like with
little things like that but good for
Reggie because it [ __ ] his career up
it ended it it did kind of it was over
he had another gear to 3 to hang around
and do things like that and he didn't
get a chance to do that because of the
injury yeah you know what though he's
proving our point grass not turf yes
uh-uh it's time for whoa big offseason
Florio you just went through the
Constitution with him we just did some
different air and Roger stuff all that
stuff's for you I'm glad we got him on
yeah it's good realize you're recording
for the first because I kind of like
just like done like this you guys we're
gonna get him on before the podcast even
started no I want to do a minute talk
about our new Odell painting is he just
gonna sit there from now on
yeah so t-shirts have been amazing you
guys are order sales are through the
roof are they really yeah they really
are
we're shipping them all over the world
we got one this morning going out to
Japan
why can't wait till people start getting
them and then sending us pictures in
like weird places you're getting one and
like let's say there's like a local
landmark that represents there that's
what I would like so like the people
that are telling me they're ordering
from Brazil or from like Pakistan yeah
like make it super Pakistani I want to
culture yeah I want to see I want it to
be like Tiananmen Square like I want it
to be perfect and to like cut the
sleeves off hold it up in the air like
do whatever you want make it you but we
want to see you guys wearing a t-shirt
so we're gonna post them all over the
place alright so the first thing that we
do with will big off seasons on
Wednesday is we take one of the wolof
seasons from Monday and we give it that
special treatment compliments of wheels
max wheeler
[Music]
what if I told you that a quarterback's
arm could be too strong that a dragon
could throw a ball a quarter-mile and
that scouting reports should be hundreds
of pages long
what if I told you that backups could
become best friends and that three-ring
binders can lead to a third ring what if
I told you
boots are not just made for walking but
for winning sins a left go presents a
whoa big offseason film big arm bigger
offseason the Davis Webster yes coming
to New Jersey New York September 2018
where do I get my tickets we also came
out three on Monday and said any of the
woven golf season's good I said Davis
Webb it's the best of all big offseason
I've ever seen yeah you're still like I
can't believe you said that I know I
cannot and I get so annoyed with the
whole like oh he's so great in the
meeting room and he does so much to
prepare this is unbelievable he's
writing notes but when it's about
someone on your team it's the best [ __ ]
ever like it really is like when I'm
reading stories about Eagles and they're
like we're like there was a there's a
wide receiver on Detroit where the
headline was undrafted rookie free agent
is turning heads and I'm like oh heads
are turning like you got you get excited
big offseason so funny well yes and we
were we're starving for anything
football why just anything in there for
an inside look or inside knowledge
that's the most annoying thing for me
walking around bleacher report this time
of the year is I have guys literally
like so give me the goods what's going
on in the end there's nothing to really
talk about right now like this is the
this is the the most intense three to
four week stretch the coaches have in
the offseason I don't get to talk too
much of them I will get more of my info
how OTAs went the last week of June the
first we could July when coaches are off
and I can catch up with some of them and
have conversations go hey how was that
rookie or what about Davis Webb yeah
does he help raise you I had nine pages
of notes there's plenty going on the NFL
yeah in fact I would argue that there's
more entertaining things go on the NFL
now than during the South talking about
like be
the scenes things but I get like real
actual things that officiants aren't big
tell me if this is big this is the first
healthy offseason for Jalen Ramsey
remember he's had two different nine
offseason surgeries and he came out and
said this year I'm trying to avoid all
that and I've been able to so if you all
thought I was good the past two years
then stay tuned that's not even a blow
big awesome that's like that's like whoa
watch the [ __ ] out here comes Jalen
Randy I've been in here in Chris's
dropped 4f by Jalen Ramsey's been the
best quarter in football and he hasn't
felt comfortable enough in the beginning
of the last two seasons oh no no what
are we gonna get we're gonna get the
Freak Show he's already been cocky what
is he gonna be now he was already been
in the conversation for the best corner
in football but he knows his body
I'm sure his dad is somebody he's worked
with for a long time he definitely has
that father-son workout thing that I
would love to watch a second Patrick
Peter said in his father on Jalen Ramsey
in his dad but also every quote from all
of his teammates yeah from the defensive
coordinator to everybody else just goes
oh no we're don't worry about Jalen
nobody we know that he's probably
working out harder away from us than
here and he said him tell van Smith oh
yeah we don't have to worry about that
Kalin's a super whoa he's definitely a
super board he's definitely like super
motivated I look at Jalen Ramsey of
being like the Odell Beckham jr. of the
defense in football like people think
he's cool and we know makes a comment
before the AFC Championship we're gonna
win that [ __ ] and all those kind of
things
he has ultimate self confidence but he
really wants to be one of the all-time
greats you can see it in his eyes the
way he plays the way he talks I do too
he's my favorite defensive player in
football there's a lot of times where
there's a big-time prospect from a
college and we compare them to a former
big-time prospect from that college and
they rarely live up yeah and for Jalen
coming out all of the comparisons were
Deion's and yes sure
prime time at Florida State and he
embraced it
yeah I love that second well big
offseason is also part of our Sims
told-you-so package on today's where
Sims told you something you doubted it
and now you should believe in Josh Allen
yeah LeSean McCoy and Josh Allen quote
I've got to be honest he's pretty good
and I'm not a big fan of rookies he
continues a little knock here that's the
one I thought was funny yeah
he throws some passes that probably
shouldn't have been thrown but other
than that he has a strong arm he's very
intelligent he's too smart
I tell him sometimes this is my favorite
part we have conversations and I say
easy this is not an exam just talk to me
Josh you can say yo you can say what's
up right
it makes me think Josh and LeSean McCoy
leshawna's like what up Josh and justice
like hello mr. it is good to see you I
am now going to have a conversation
where I express my leadership and desire
to be I think you're right I think
that's the kind of guy he is he's trying
to eat once and he's so good and then he
says there's a talent level he's gonna
be really good for a lot of years yeah
so when a super talented like I look at
LeSean McCoy as one of the best running
backs in his generation when he says
this praise about Josh Allen Sims you
told him so I I mean yes I do get
gratification out of these type of
stories because you know these are
things where I feel like I was a little
ahead of the curve being able to throw
it out there and of course I guys know I
can't tell people here my sources but
you guys know I know the right people do
convey these messages and I do I like
the the justification of it and this is
just the other thing to know the know
it's real to write like LeSean McCoy
told you he don't like rookies and what
does that mean because he means you you
got to do something to her my respect
before I'm starting to talk about you to
the media like you've done something but
I think that Josh Allen whatever hearing
has some eye popping talent that even
guys like LeSean McCoy are like McCoy or
like Danny hasn't done anything yet but
he's got a chance to do something
because it's it's real so that's what I
like about it if you thought that was a
whoa whoa the woe of the week is Lamar
Jackson again Sims told you so not only
did Sims told you so
he said that the
probably gonna start experimenting a
practice and training camp about getting
them both in the field and what do you
know the Ravens are using two
quarterbacks Lamar Jackson all over the
field first a quote by John Harbaugh
quote gosh I sure like him out there
helping us we have to figure out Jo has
to be able to do other things if Lamar
is throwing the ball so he's challenged
Marty morningway and Greg Roman to come
up with finding a way to get them both
on the field and it's catching the eye
of the defense and CJ Mosley has the woe
of the week quote once he gets out of
the pocket it's like watching a young
Michael Vick quarterback it's amazing to
watch when you're defending him you have
to act like you're just tagging off it's
not funny don't want to be on the
highlight that's so funny because that's
really what happens with these kind of
guys right so because you can't tackle
you can't hit right especially not the
quarterback yeah but you're supposed to
go if Josh is the quarter and the runner
right and you're a linebacker you're
supposed to get up close to him and then
give almost like a form tackled act like
right you know I would have got him
right there now guys like him for
Charlie garner who I was around or
Cadillac Williams
you know guys would just do this but you
weren't even close to him like there's
no way you were gonna actually tackle
him that was a nice little fool act like
you were gonna get but I got a kick out
of that mental picture because I'm sure
he's breaking ankles and I'm sure some
of these defenders are like oh crap I'm
not even close to him let me just give
the forum tackle I'm waiting for the
training camp I in the sky footage to be
released
yes of some of these plays because
that's what I need I need to see Lamar
Hawk the outside but we now have almost
every member of this defense talking
about Lamar Jackson the coaching staff
it must be sensational is I mean again
this is where scouting just goes
overboard it's over scouting is but
again like I said what Josh Allen a few
weeks ago yes Lamar Jackson is made to
make people say whoa big offseason when
they're in when they're in short yeah I
get that but these are guys that have
around the Michael Vick's in the world
and know what the hell that's like so
they've seen it you know Eric Weddle
those guys they've seen it in action to
go damn
I remember chasing that mf'er and this
guy is just like that maybe worse yeah I
mean again I know he was in the perfect
quarterback but it just goes into over
oh so you're telling me the best player
in college football the last two years
has been good in OTAs I'm shocked when
does Joe start to get pissed Josie is
there any guy he's pissed
he's from sure he's pissed as hell to
see your teammates go to the media like
that let's go start when you're the
veteran you've won a Super Bowl right
over to that CJ Mosely in one other part
of his quote yeah said it's cool to see
that we can switch things up with
quarterbacks and then this part as long
as we don't have Joe doing too much
running that's all that really matters
is it this guy's incredible but just
don't don't run because he's not even
like athletic it's really magnifying all
the things that Joe doesn't do well
right like the one thing that Joe
probably had a lot of quarterbacks is he
could throw it further yeah but I bet
you Lamar just gum are can make some
eye-opening throws yeah yeah that can be
what does Joe do that's better than
Lamar yeah no that's it's gonna that's
gonna affect you it's the first time Joe
is having to deal with the real
adversity in his NFL career which is
really annoying it's the first time
where you go man other than starting as
a rookie well yeah but this is more like
at least the organization every
everybody backed him then he's never
going to the first time of where man and
owner GM coach they're all doubting me
not everybody's in my corner here
anymore flock things this entire career
if you think about it's been kind of
embattled with questions the entire is
Joe Flacco elite thing yeah is like its
own zone meme yeah it's like its own
which it was way better than people ever
gave him credit for I'd like to that to
be stated he's more athletic than people
gave me one of the greatest playoff runs
that we've ever seen from a quarterback
and that is noted and it is in history
but then I would say the last three four
years of Joe Flacco he's had to try and
convince people as a personality yeah
for the last three four years he's like
I'm not a wet rag I'm not a wet rag I'm
not a wet rag he's honest Ray Lewis
never say anything interesting he takes
a lot of heat for that Flacco has gotten
weird adversary' adversity but now this
is the first like Ross
like challenging his actual physical
ability and yeah you know what was the
point you made there that I wanted to
dive in onto with Flacco there's
something you said right there before
that damn it about teammates talking up
yeah yeah you can't run on credit for
doing what is Joe Flacco do better than
the macho yes okay so you talked about
it like the playoff runs he had there
for a few years it was phenomenal I mean
was doing it's the Patriots all they
were up 20 to 40 what he has performed
Brady and every playoff game he's
playing against Brady really so and it's
it's really good one too but again I
think this is another area of where you
see like you don't give yourself the
benefit of the doubt when you act
certain ways in a locker room or it or
not that guy right and he is the
quarterback and when he was really
playing at a high level we could swipe
under the rug the lack of leadership the
lack of personality all that because
damn look at that 70 or Bobby just threw
screw all that other stuff he keeps
doing that you can do whatever he wants
but now the often struggles he struggled
he gets hurt and now everyone's like
damn that attitude sucks too to go along
with it last year was the worst I've
ever seen him play like he had an
interception by Ryan shazier where you
wrote in your notes yeah what even was
joking Yeah right I know it was a bad
one that was when I remember it was like
in a week it was early on maybe week two
yeah he doesn't have a lot of help
around him the offense was very average
as far as you know creativity last year
those the first time you said Joe's not
doing that now he's not he's not making
those big throws that I said like I used
to go damn he make three or four throws
every game where I'd go there's only a
few guys in football before they played
the Steelers lost 26 nine was bad all
right let's call Phil I just Nick what
number we're gone awesome all right so
people are starting to figure out how to
call Phil the first three when you gave
away the area code and then they've been
they've been picking off numbers in the
middle there's only like five numbers
left for the public to go so we got to
be careful also if we gotta make my dad
change its cell phone number because the
podcast listeners blowing him up so what
we're gonna do with Phil he's in
Louisville right now really yeah he's a
Louisville seeing the family
season 4 fell seeing the fam seeing the
Kentucky fam yes I'm sure
LT I feel guilty because I need to see
my Kentucky family I need to call them
all I'm Mike I love that you're from
Kentucky kind of bad family member
hello hello my god you guys I figured
about 2:45 you'd be calling me so you
know you're getting better we're getting
there the blood
fill out there where were you last week
you ditched us and I felt lonely we left
you a voicemail yeah what was I doing I
was doing something and I said look what
was I doing
you're playing ping pong probably did a
little you and Deirdre playing big you
didn't feel well I think is what
basically happened if I share that with
everybody what a baby yeah yeah whatever
you know hey listen I I can't remember
so that's it last Wednesday I don't you
know what day it is now get the twinsies
so cuz I'm talking to you two idiots yes
but but it's all good I'm down in
Louisville Kentucky I hear I hear you're
down there visiting the grave site for
that doggie punched no I didn't kill the
damn dog I did my brother is he told you
it once to make it quick after he kicked
the dog he lived across the street damn
I think it broke apart by Dominic
Dominic probably deserved a broken foot
what that I said Dominic probably
deserved a broken foot yeah you know
making us help him deliver papers he
didn't even pay us so that was
unbelievable Don not surprised yeah
you're not surprised but I'm gonna see
that thing tomorrow night and you know
all I said to him you know one day Don
they come I'll get even with you I'm
gonna beat the crap out of you oh we're
just trying you can't bid no I think I
can oh okay I think you need to do the
Terry Bradshaw skiing joke to Donovan
Donovan
Domenic no cuz he's if I did it no he's
getting old and frail you might you
might knock them out mother brother Joe
the other night so I'm gonna see him in
a few maybe tonight or whatever you know
what our conversation is Christopher
knows and he's been mouth was full of
Dominic and I got to get into em you
think anything that Christopher says on
your podcast radio or TVs crazy my
oldest brother is off the rails
you're like oh my god yes he's crazy
politically not correct and so out of
place
what don't tell me we're gonna do one of
these
I'm my first question for The Sims the
Raiders have cut Hackenberg and I'm
curious for both of you guys what I'm
really shocked I can't believe it you
know look he had such a great freshman
year at Penn State
he was really terrific did you watch the
game well whatever I was gonna happen
why don't we say this to you Adam I
wasn't surprised he went in the second
round what's beyond shocked right that
he went the second round I gave it a go
- great on the draft coverage dad and
when they did it oh my gosh what did we
learn I loved all the rhetoric can I
like this why do you know I need to go
back and read always say this because
I'm gonna go back and read what
everybody said it was always the same
thing well you know he was in a offense
under Bill O'Brien I don't know
well what did we learn from this like
everything really exploded if the if the
NFL could learn one thing from the whole
Hackenberg alike situation what does you
guys take away from it when you don't
throw the ball very well or not even
close it's not good enough for the NFL
then what are you drafting yes yeah
value eighty right go ahead sorry well
yeah if these were large actions and
maybe might throw an errant pass I don't
know you know I liked him even though he
had a dynamic he makes a lot of dynamic
throws but you know it unless there is
something else that's so overwhelming
that it doesn't matter which I can't
imagine what that would be for an NFL
quarterback and that's it you know the
Jets said it all many many times
preseason play they had probably in two
years what would you say you guys ten
opportunities to play around draft pick
quarterback and it was basically never
considered right so that says it all
so they trading why today trading
because it makes everybody look good all
we trading we got something back for the
course you knew it was done and that the
Raiders we're gonna let him go as soon
as they go chance yeah do you think this
officially ends it now like the or do
you think somebody's going to give it
one more pick him up Bill O'Brien in the
board yeah that's right yeah I know so
let's pick him up and I've seen it I
can't think who else reminds me of that
but you know they we got evidence
I don't know if we do or not because we
never saw him playing a game except a
few preseason games yep but whatever
would transpire didn't mean to be mean
the Christian Hackenberg not at all but
whatever transpired I mean it meant
evidence enough the Jets were desperate
for a quarterback and they don't put him
on the field yet didn't even buy him in
his first preseason you're right they
didn't even play him at all his first
preseason I that's unprecedented for a
second-round pick and then last
preseason I know you dummy we do know
yes they were telling you you're not
listening what they told you by not
playing in the preseason they told you
because they didn't start him at the end
of the year both years many
opportunities to plane and you know hey
we want to worry about Oh winning let's
just getting some experience because we
think he has a chance in the future
they didn't do that so those but it'll
be interesting I will not be shocked of
course somebody will pick him up yeah
someone one other there's gotta be
there's one other stupid team out there
that'll do it
but what we've learned is this just as
usual I'll like even use this is a worse
version of Deshawn Kaiser right where I
say this where this is this is the love
affair of oh he was a top recruit and he
played for Bill O'Brien
and look how handsome he is and so
well-spoken and he looks so good in
front of the podium he looks like he
should be our franchise quarterback and
he had that little success that freshman
year with that pro coach so he must be a
pro that's where we learned it's it's
it's again it's like dad said don't
evaluate the other the most important
thing is evaluate the player on the
field and and for some reason a
quarterback every now and then we find
all these justifications not to evaluate
what's on the field and we find out
these other formulas to what its gonna
make successful Jay Manuel is a lot like
that to out-of-state he was such a
leader the coaches yeah art at least it
goes wrong like that what that le CJ can
throw it J is Aaron Rodgers next the
Christian Hackenberg
that's right that's amazing alright so
there you go so Phil let's go back to
this here's what well don't look at his
sophomore and junior years look at his
freshman year now you know I what I was
on is doing games at the time so on
Saturdays early you know we have time
off so I was always watching Penn State
and I said well let me see this
Christian Hackenberg okay and I'd watch
Michael I know he's a freshman and but I
don't see it yeah I go I just don't see
it so again I'm sorry to be so hard on
him
no you know you know but he got drafted
in the second round there were more that
he had many many opportunities but the
evidence had to be so overwhelming to
the Jets that they weren't even gonna
put him out there to what to expose
themselves yes that's all what explode
them right so when the trade was made I
really thought it was made okay they're
making it they know they both okay and
and I expected the Raiders to releasing
I didn't think they were releasing this
quick yeah they did because the Raiders
EJ Manuel and Connor cook you know they
both are somewhat high draft picks and
there is athletic is Christian
Hackenberg and they don't know right all
right so Phil I came away very impressed
with your trash-talking a few weeks ago
and so I found three instances in this
past week of accidental insults where
someone in the NFL said something and I
went oh would the other guy be pissed so
I want to do a little rapid-fire you and
Chris would you be pissed if you were
the other guy first one Cole Beasley was
asked about the new wide receivers coach
Sanjay Lal and Dallas and he says it
feels like the first time we're actually
being taught how to run routes instead
of just naturally doing things if you're
Derek Dooley are you pissed the old wide
receiver coach for the Cowboys well yeah
I would be upset but you know what for
Cole Beasley to say that it's it must
have been an issue and drove them crazy
and you know look at you I've heard this
story many times so what they're really
big pissed yes but you know what Cole
Beasley is really mad too
that's what I take out of it okay yeah
and if there was any kind of admiration
or respect for whatever that it whatever
of course is not there to come out but
statement like that cold Beasley knows
that is really condemning of a man well
coach yeah definitely that was a direct
shot to Derek Dooley to basically be
like you didn't teach us anything and
now we're being taught something and
this is fun I'm getting better for the
first time which I always wondered why
the hell he was the wide receiver I'm
telling you the first episode of the All
or Nothing for the Cowboys
it's Derek Dooley and Dez Bryant going
back and forth and yelling at each other
and I want to be like maybe that was the
reason Dez didn't like being in Dallas
so much
like his position coach if you don't
respect your position coach
it must be infuriating to be in a room
with him all the [ __ ] time yeah man
listen when you're a pro your coach has
got to be able to tell you something and
they can't they can't fool you and I've
watched really good wide receiver
coaches in the NFL and then you know I
go wow and then I've even done this
watch pace well then these receivers are
machines they line up they get the
perfect stance
they take the perfect steps you know all
this stuff all the time and you know and
just doing all the throwing we do all
the time during the summer and I watch
certain receivers there near pros or
whatever some of the things they do
they're teaching kids they go it is
awesome
so being a wide receiver isn't just like
hey I'm really good I'm just gonna go
out there and do it right you know
there's a lot of technique a lot of and
a tremendous amount that you can teach
them and you know the great thing now is
all the videos when we call the kids and
we stop sometimes you don't the
receivers are doing they're over there
on their phone hey look at this move by
Julian Edelman let's do this when we run
the next route from this position and
you know Julian Edelman is going out
there doing a Skip hop and jump and
making cuts and I just go wow that's
really cool yeah who can cover that no
but don't do what Julian Edelman does in
his off time yeah Sammy Sammy Watkins go
ahead okay Sammy Watkins was talking
about Patrick mahomes and he said quote
I came here to be with a young guy that
I can grow with are you pissed if you're
jarred golf hmm because Jared Goff is
the same age as Patrick Holmes but Sammy
Watkins said I want to be with a young
guy that I can grow with I'm also going
to add to this that he you said quote it
was a good thing where I went to the
Rams and went through the situation of
getting open and showing what I could do
playing without the ball which was kind
of like I was open and I never going to
frickin bomb yeah I did not I read the
first part of the quote and I just went
well yeah okay it's
you know he knows he's coming to a new
place and he can get on the same page
and connect with Patrick mahomes and be
the man in Kansas City right now you
know Wow do they have some speed-sew yes
it may be a little direct shot at jarrod
golf but that one doesn't I don't think
equal Kobe's least called Yeah right I'm
with you - yes it is it's a little bit
of a knock their eye and and yeah I
think he's just being honest where he
wanted to go with a young guy that he
could go out with that wasn't saying
that it was a certain young guy I just
have all the young this is a good one
Sammy's pissed he was open a lot and and
I think this has to be noted I'll say
this I don't know I don't know if dad
feels the same way this but the most
overrated football player in football
going into the 2018 season is Jared golf
I'm just gonna let everybody out there
know the fact that people were he's
towards the top of the list for NFL MVP
and all that stuff that's just yeah
that's insane and in Vegas he's like one
of the top 10 MVP candidates I believe
that is insane people don't realize
Jared Goff had a better year last year
it was definitely a big step up from the
rookie year but that offense was amazing
not because of Jared golf's physical
ability but because of the play design
third and 51 yard screens four
touchdowns against the New York Giants
80 yard there was a time Gurley right 80
yard screens to Todd Gurley Todd Gurley
led the team in receptions last year so
that to me is one of the more annoying
things in the NFL landscape right now
Jared Goff could still be awesome and
he's on the right track I'm not trying
to just downplay him but for people to
be putting him in the NVB conversation
his number seven he's number seven
that's insane for Vegas if you're gonna
push back against the media mainstream
which we like to do when it's some
stupid takes that stupid take number one
for me in this offseason okay sorry it's
up there for you it's pretty high yeah
it's up there I don't know if it'd be
number one baby in my top five for sure
yeah and you know I had this
conversation Christopher you know Adam I
telling me things we talked and we were
talking about on the draft and we're
going on and again I go you know he'll I
don't know bill what's more important a
franchise quarterback Kirk
offensive coordinator and you know
failed like oh that's man that's tough
question he goes I don't know it might
be the coordinator yeah laughing I go
yeah because the coordinators are making
SARS and John McVay made Jared golf last
year and it wasn't Jared golf making
them so that that absolute Tom Brady is
a great talent but he is playing for one
of the best all-time offensive
coordinators in the NFL drew Brees
is of course gonna lead everything in
all this and I give him credit he's
tough he's athletic he don't give enough
credit to is that like a billion all
that yeah but he of course is playing
with one of the all-time offensive
coordinators in history right in history
right so it's amazing in it how when you
look at good quarterbacks what do they
have in common of course it seems pretty
good but they have a coordinator who can
really really help you that's why and
that's why Rogers that's why Rogers and
Russell Wilson are so incredible exactly
they don't have that exactly alright
last one really good point
Thanks well they don't get they don't
get 15 just one guy that is up there
with those offensive coordinators he
came from that Shanahan Jon Gruden Trias
Jay Gruden and this is our last was this
an insult talking about Alex Smith he
said quote one thing about Alex he's the
smartest guy I have ever been around
without a doubt if you're Kirk Cousins
are you pissed okay am I pissed if I'm
Kirk because we know that Kirk Cousins
owns like the title of nerdiest
quarterback like he sits in a room he
has all the notes I watched videos of
him he gets really excited josh of
quarterbacks yes Bendrick but yeah are
you upset I'm not mad if I'm Kirk
Cousins okay you proved your point you
stuck it to Washington and they had to
pay you and you left
and you know I heard that same comment
all the smartest guy I've ever been with
you know I heard that about Ryan
Fitzpatrick 50 times yeah okay well how
come he's thrown in the middle of the
pack all the time right Oh cuz that was
a smart move I don't know so yeah that's
that thing the smartest and oh my gosh
oh they're just all the course my
favorite quote of all my real pet Pete
you know our quarterback Rover is really
good you know the guys all like your
quarterback oh my god please give me a
break you know your quarterback room is
really good when you got a franchise
big-time superstar quarterback that's
what it's good that's right we just
killed it just a little while ago we
were talking about we just before you
got on we were talking about all he's
good in the quarterback room
he writes great notes we were talking
about Davis Webb because that's the
story that's being pushed out about him
this week so that got me up but I'm not
like offended by that if I'm Kirk
Cousins smarts doesn't mean mean at all
it doesn't mean anything actually it
really doesn't I mean I know hey I was
what quarterbacks ever a lot smarter
than me and the books and other things
and answering questions they got on the
field and they'd go what was that cover
two or cover three and I'm gonna be like
damn you're the smartest guy the damn
team you couldn't tell there was two
safeties that time so it doesn't know
doesn't mean anything
hey you know when you're smart too is
the quarterback when you get throw bad
dang ball exactly where you want it to
go exactly you can sort an exact speed
as you want to go at amazing how you get
really smart he sees it versus the
window he's gonna get it through there
yeah yeah really
wow I'm shocked Phil you ready for a
move Phil you ready for this week's
mascot battle by the way real by the way
film this did for 25 minutes something
come on
all right so pick pick who's going first
and then I'll tell you which one is
which are you go first okay Phil I am a
charger and Chris is a saint
so really mate
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what's the charger were you well I heard
you I am a bolt you gotta charge my
battery
I am a bullet I'm a bolt of lightning
fill so in essence I want you to decide
whether or not this saint and his
prayers can prevent him from science
this is a battle of the Lord and Zeus
this is nature versus religion so you
have to ask yourself one question like
your thing in there but go ahead here is
young Christopher standing in a field a
priest praying to the heavens and I am
just a bolt of lightning and you have to
ask yourself one question Phil the more
he prays can he prevent himself from
being electrocuted I don't forget it
possible what would you say to your
father well I mean I'm a saint okay
lightning doesn't hit Saints all right
hey Jay doesn't know God God makes
thunder and lightning and he shall not
strike down upon me
because I am a Messenger of God I am a
sinner all I've done so now crime maybe
if I prayed and asked God to strike me
down the lightning cuz I wanted to get
to the afterlife maybe consider it so
you're telling that you think your power
enough you think that you're just as a
powerful as God to control lightning I
think God has enough for your next
message for my good deeds on this planet
and all the good I'm doing that he would
go Oh young Christopher thy Saint whose
done so good for the world
Alan geing the weapon we don't have
strike down upon thee on the Saints of
the world for all the good that you have
done against that's all I got done
I've been a long time dad yeah I think
well my mother was alive oh I know
now it's Christopher your kids are going
to church right you know
I don't know what they do I know all
right here we go this is really really
easy today the winner is and it is like
a boxing match that went 12 rounds and
it is a just 10 9 every round Adam left
oh hey good job left cause really son
you lost when you took the role as the
same I mean I just said you're going I
don't even need to hear any more
arguments you know the jury's already
decision and it's over opening comments
it was over good job Christopher yeah no
I I'm gonna get out my Bible here in the
room yeah and write down see if I can
come up with some more words for you and
be thou shall not strike upon thee I am
thy son of Phil Simms yeah that might be
good extra lightning ball better watch
out all right dad we're done with you we
have no more use for you have fun in
Kentucky you know I get from a lot of
people so that's okay move on somebody
else is pulled in for a while what
happened that was awesome thanks tell
everybody I said hi see you pal man it's
good to finally get a win oh it's been a
long time in the maze he's got such a
kick out of that
he laughed that was a legitimate Phil
Simms laughing when he heard that I'm
not gonna lie when he laughed
I went damn I'm really his son because
when I got this text last night and you
sent it to me I laughed just like that
and my wife was like what are you
laughing at and I'm like oh like in the
same thing sound just like by the way I
just got an alert on the BR app Eric
Weddle can tell Joe Flacco has obviously
been challenged this offseason and it's
shown in his performance yes apparently
look Flacco has been playing better too
apparently all the walls go to Lamar
yeah no that's there's I would expect
that it's put a poker up his butt here
and he's he's on his game so I don't
think we've seen
as many holdout discussions this year I
think we're seeing more this year than
we have in years past yeah levy on David
Johnson now I know Taylor Lewan Odell
Beckham saying I don't want to perform
in team practices again another Sims
told you so yeah that's what Odell's
coming out but I want to show you three
examples as to why many camps and what
we're experiencing right now are
unnecessary no one wants to be there and
we need to stop villainizing the players
that are not going first example of
they're unnecessary if you had to say
that there's one team in which practice
is going to be the most important the
most rigorous the hardest they make a
run
it's the Patriots well guess what
Patriots players were informed yesterday
that it was gonna be the last day of
training camp and that they're sent home
on Thursday and Friday because they've
been doing a great job
Bill Belichick knows that this [ __ ] is
not important and the only thing that
happens is he has to answer questions
every day about Brady and Gronk and
Edelman and he says it's not important
if the Patriots can cancel them then
anyone can cancel they're unnecessary no
one wants to be there amazing quote here
from haha Clinton dicks yeah I'm excited
not to have a bonus in there because I
would have definitely had to be there
for the money you can't buy time just
have the freedom to be able to get away
I think that's a plus not having it
talking about a thing in this contract
to get a bonus I'm a guy and I need my
money that's why I'm here now I need my
money he doesn't want to be there it's
so not players don't want to be there so
so bad that jpp turned down a two
hundred and fifty thousand dollar bonus
because he just didn't want to be there
so all the players don't want to be
there it's not just the stars and the
last one about why we have to stop
villainizing the players if there's one
position that we know follows the rules
its offensive line and Zack Martin when
asked about his hold up hold out said it
was tough this is the best line if you
would have asked I never would have
thought in a million years I'd be the
guy holding out and not come
into things but that's just the way it
kind of worked out at the end of the day
I had to make a decision it was hard but
best for me that was it yeah no one
thinks they're going to be the holdout
play nobody wants the baby on right
David Johnson they all think they're
gonna get taken care of but you realize
that the only leverage you have is not
showing up and if Zack Martin can be
honest and say I never thought I was
gonna be the guy then we need to realize
that all of the players never thought
they were going to be the guy because
they all thought they were gonna be
taken care of right they're not
important
they don't want to be there stop
villainizing them they're just trying to
negotiate yes I mean so many good points
there I mean you're all over it I think
the thing is first of all this is why
you see sometimes the star player sign a
contract like a Julio ern Aaron Rodgers
that they don't like because they are
like Zach Martin was saying I never
expected that guy I'm the team guy I
love football I love being around it but
then it comes time to sign the contract
and the team goes man Aaron it would
really make it a lot better if he'd add
an extra year on because it could make
the less blow on the salary cap and and
here Aaron goes well I am the
quarterback and I want to win and okay
I'll do it for the team and he does it
for the team and then he goes here he is
with two years left in the contract he
goes that's stupid I should have done
that or whatever I got screwed Julio
saying the same thing so that's one
thing that goes into my brain when you
talked about all that the other thing
okay oth you're right that this is not
that important Tom Brady knows how to
throw the slant round and the curl round
feels like it's more important for the
rookies to get adjusted to the rest
dream yes agreed and hey listen is it
important for players and and I mean
like the Brady's of the world do they
need to get out there and get some reps
and things like that yes do it agree do
they need 14 Oh TA s to do that no they
do not need that
and now you've we've talked about how
you need to be training right yeah you
know there's a reason levy on bail and
Aaron Donald's of the world who didn't
do anything they played the whole season
last year because their body was trained
the way they thought it needed to be
trained hit their specific trainer for
their specific position and not having
to listen to one trainer who's training
90 guys
doesn't all they don't all have the
exact same skill set and things they
need to do or be better at on the field
so that plays into it right then the
other thing is this would be my other
thing you get towards the end of TAS and
coaches there we made it through we had
no big injuries let maybe we should just
cut off the last day or yeah cuz we've
done it let's get out and then the other
thing is the it's the coaches are going
training can't start some 28 days I need
20 days of divine they did be able to
get drunk and do everything I want to do
for 24 days straight from Mira I was
like if I leave now I can I can get top
key I can get some short stacks of
blueberry bag I can get to Nantucket and
play six extra rounds of golf they're
all stressing right now that's what
happens to it this time sure the coaches
I have to pee I'm gonna pause the
podcast if you guys want to talk I never
had to be this bad man I was wondering
you were starting to make me
uncomfortable
alright he was going like this like and
I was like what is he doing I cut here
and we're back you peed thank God but
more importantly you asked another man
to be the third person in his bedroom
and a hotel for know Beyonce yeah but
then I ended up buying my own hotel him
what a shocker
I mean Wow whoa thanks thanks for doing
that you were gonna bunk with him and
his girl on a road trip and I figured if
there's one couple that I don't have to
worry about being a burden to I think
that the him and his fiance really enjoy
my company they do you know I was giving
them a favor
but once 9 o'clock it's the your burden
okay yeah they want to go to the room
Josh throw on a movie right think about
my relationship with Josh and his
fiancee is for the beginning of their
relationship I was the weird third wheel
that was like Josh stay out a little bit
longer come on Josh come on Josh you're
gonna you're gonna stop playing beer
pong now like I would say the devil on
my shoulder
yes so there's part of me that wanted to
rekindle it so when did she start to
finally like Adam because she's always
like though me but I use the
weighing guys annoying friend that's
like I would say probably at the end of
football 2015 when we stopped going it
was like every Thursday
me and Josh we're giving the listeners a
lot right now me and Josh would go to
the 13-step and we would never lose beer
pong looking right I don't think that
entire season like I think if we tallied
it up we probably went like 55 and no
loose yet maybe lost one game we lost
one and then immediately it was like
we're gonna beat her we actually we lost
to a British guy I remember who started
talking I want ass man to me and let go
just went up to him is that you're gonna
talk smack to my guy I almost got into a
fight yeah I caught what did I call his
accent ooh
soft no I was like I was like I don't
know if this accent is real because it
sounds like [ __ ] but like get out of my
face yeah I was really big apparently a
single left goes oh now I go I go
Thursday I go that's what I eat Thai and
don't do anything just like every other
week I'm always telling about 13 stab
all right so I got one a few more things
then we got to start wrapping it up by
meeting Josh Gordon 30 Josh Gordon said
the Browns have the best wide receiver
core in the NFL right wait first of all
is it core or Corp core I mean I spelled
CEO RPS but that's a core why receiving
core I did not know that so this is why
receiver corpse I just was confused
yesterday when I saw a few of those
headlines I was like wait is that I
might be mispronouncing this word all
along I didn't know you could say they
have a great core of young wide
receivers which would be cor E so it
depends upon how you're using it I
always see ORP it depends I didn't know
that the wide receiving core so what did
you think they were saying like he's
saying it's a core of guys that we have
agree but when you saw the corpse I was
like man I don't understand like is that
like corporation I didn't understand it
I was we thought you're like you're like
have the Browns wide receivers have an
LLC are they independent contract I
really I was very I was I didn't know I
love that we got that iron I'm so happy
first thing I like to say yes he's
absolutely right
I think the Browns have the best wide
receiving core
not the top three but when you realize
that they have Ricardo Lewis back then
or chard Higgins no way
keep going go keep going oh I didn't
okay I think all those geysers are great
athletes like when I see Ricardo Lewis I
go if he was on another team we'd be
hearing a lot of whoa big offseason I
think that they're like Arvid same name
the rest of the court for me that was
the whole and then there's Josh Morgan
it wasn't played in two years and Corey
Coleman who hasn't done anything yeah I
think that they're super deep they have
potential yes that is yeah I do not
think that they have the best y
receiving trio all right I didn't look
this up of mine go ahead on I actually I
have the top one two three four
I went nine deep I believe the top wide
receiver tree or the NFL is Atlanta okay
I think that Julio Jones Mohamed Sanu
Calvin Ridley is the best trio my number
two and you stop me when you think
that's a good one
i I don't even know mine yet number two
is Pittsburgh Antonio Brown jugo Smith
Schuester Hayward Bay because I think
that I'm not saying that hayward Bay has
potential but I'm saying solid and I
think juju and intentional right my
number three is Landry Gordon Coleman
and I know that that sounds crazy but I
think that I have a lot of faith in
Gordon and if we were buying stock I'm
buying stock in Josh Gordon for this
year maybe it's the picture of the
tricep that everybody was sharing but
him and Landry I think go to really well
together they might be a little high my
number four is Oakland I'm going Amari
Cooper Jordy Nelson martavis Bryant and
you can make arguments that they're
ahead of Cleveland for me I would say
they're ahead of Cleveland you would
pick a Maori Jordy in Martellus support
martavis Bryant above them I would yeah
I could see that yeah my next one after
that I was battling between three teams
the rams chiefs and Bucks Rams I picked
to be the highest because I think
Brandon cooks Robert Woods Cooper Cup I
put them in front of the Browns too just
because like the Browns I know their
potential might be greater than Southie
and that's the thing is I look
Cook's and woods and cop and I go there
solid yes but if Josh Gordon hits his
potential yes Josh Gordon and Landry
it's gonna be better than almost anybody
else in the NFL right because Gordon he
could be incredible
yeah the Chiefs tyree kill Sammy Watkins
and Chris Connelly
I put Tyree killin like the he was
better than a lot of other teams number
ones like he's the kind of guy that I go
I'm comparing him to Josh Gordon not
Landry I'm comparable Watkins to Landry
and he'll I think that Josh Gordon I
Tyree kill is being under Tyree kill is
in the conversation for best receiver in
football I agree I mean I had to do a
draft on pft with best receivers in the
sport
I took Tyree kill three and he goes what
you didn't take AJ Green I said I don't
think he's as good as Tyree killed right
now that was just my honest answer sorry
kill where we don't compare him to great
wide receivers because he's small yes
but I go I didn't see other guys scoring
80 yard touchdowns like that's a skill
right the Tampa Bay Bucs the reason I
have them up there Mike Evans DeSean
Jackson Chris Godwin mm-hmm I'm a big
believer in Chris Godwin next year and I
think Mike Evans is like what Josh
Gordon could be but I think that Landry
is better than - Sean Jackson I'm just
comparing around just cool yeah then I
thought of the Chargers Keenan Allen
Travis Benjamin Mike Williams I just
there's not a number two for the
Chargers yet like even the the other guy
Tyrone Williams right like I like Travis
Benjamin but I see him as like a three I
just I do yeah I understand he's a 3 or
a 2 with a caveat whatever it may be I
understand that man that's an impressive
group right there though yes I mean even
without good core they are that is a
good core all those guys can do a little
bit of everything Williams yeah but then
you know which one that I I threw in
there as they're definitely not the top
but they're really interesting and no
one's gonna talk about them Washington
yes
Paul Richardson right Jameson Crowder
who's one of the best slots in the game
and Josh docks it yes and I go if
Doctson hits his potential
Robinson's the deep threat and Crowder's
like this great underneath guy that was
a wide receiving core
I actually really liked but I know it's
not the top yeah
so my tops are Atlanta Pitt Oakland the
Rams Chiefs and Browns
what do you think I think you're those
are those are teams yeah I think those
teams are the top I mean I don't I
wouldn't rank Cleveland that high as you
do right I just have a lot of faith in
Josh Gordon I hear that yeah no I don't
think you're dumb I think it's it's real
it's just been two years and I just got
to see it before I guess I throw him
into that class but yeah he's in this
this list regardless Cleveland is in
this list with their guys I'm trying to
think if there's anything else you
missed out there that's interesting to
me you know like I of course I always
think of the Giants but the core the
core is not that special that was my
thing as I when do we tell like worse
you know I know we could have received
it was not counting like everything no
because because then Kansas City goes to
the top yes because then it's tyree kill
Sammy Watkins and Kelsey yeah you know
but then also we're doing the Patriots
where it's like Edelman Hogan and Gronk
right now but no just wide receiving
corpse right that's kind of how I came
in Joyce's sneaky get roid is up there
like if I mentioned in Washington I
mentioned Detroit with gala day Tate and
Marvin Jones exact very very good very
good yeah I think those are the teams
though that are in this discussion with
me that Lana's number one julio sanu and
ridley I just think that Julio and Sanu
is the best one too
because sanu I think is more athletic
than Landry and Julio is like the best
case scenario for Josh Gordon Antonio
Brown and juju I just think juju super
reliable and Antonio Brown is a truly
elite I like that one-two punch better
than the Atlanta's one-two punch because
I do like Brown and juju better than
Jesse and I think Julio's better than
brown but not by a ton and then I do
think juju is a clear notch above sinew
right I just thought that Ridley had
more potential than hey Roy I think
that's that would be yes so that would
be probably the edge you give Atlanta in
the hole but I think Oakland is very
slow and is
there again there's there's pictures of
Amari Cooper being enormous again this
offseason
if whoa whoa big Amari like he's always
blow like he he left sweet and he just
expands his potential you get a year of
Jordi being a reliable guy and martavis
Bryant like martavis Bryant is Josh
Gordon yeah they are equal in terms of
athleticism that's very right up there
with him he's not quite the size of the
man Josh Gordon is like he doesn't have
those triceps but yes in a race and
their prime actually I'm taking more
Davis Brian I think we're gonna see the
martavis Bryant we saw two years ago
that was the star not you know you got
to remember last year it's a weird year
when you haven't been around football
year you get thrown in they just drafted
a receiver
he couldn't kind of find his way and get
comfortable enough to where he could
really make his mark I think he makes
his mark big-time this year in Oakland
man I would like that yeah this happened
last week Jalen Ramsey tweeted at Dez
Bryant and said hey man come to
Jacksonville there's nothing I want more
than Dez Bryant in Jacksonville I can
make the argument they don't have a lot
of good experienced wide receivers he
would get along great with the defense
and after week one the truth that he
would spin about Blake bortles it would
be past whoa Prescott Blake well that
was the other one I actually was like
when you started talking about like
receiving quarters I thought about them
for a second because they have a lot of
those but no nobody like Dede West right
they have some potential guys DJ shark
and all those kind of guys I go okay so
I apologize to the media no you can't
take it back now you're coming up on
Monday we're gonna be recording this
this afternoon
fender ik got how many questions would
you say hundreds a ton it's we used to
be a time where it will be Seahawks
Scout and mark bait but now left goes
burner accounts just making up questions
so we had a shot we actually have gotten
hundreds of fan and listener questions
and tweets and instagrams and DMS
pendrick has put them all into one dock
and on Monday we are going to have a fan
mail fan mail bag podcast school
bag I don't know their backpacks or sins
peace out homies for fender good night
everybody
guys I want to say thank you for all the
support with the t-shirts thank you for
the the the websites and the instagrams
from all of what are you talking about
you gave us websites people I didn't
know that thanks to the websites man and
a Hawaiian shirt all right love you guys
say hotel you're the man to see you guys
later peace